dyslexia however to me is a competitive
weapon
you have to take this like a superpower
that's
unconstrained and focus it you have to
use it as a tool
it's the out-of-the-box thinkers that
make
companies competitive the crazy ones the
dyslexic ones
[Music]
talk to us about how old you were when
you were when you learned that you were
dyslexic and what was it like for you
and your family
when you got that diagnosis well
dyslexia gets misdiagnosed
all the time but the way it manifests
itself with a young child
is when they start to fall behind in
reading and math
testing that's the first time it usually
shows up in a concerning way because
it's not a small
delta it's a large one i think i was
about seven years old when it became
a real concern to my mother who was
wondering why i was falling behind in
school and her teachers were saying look
he's just not focused he's not
concentrating
but that wasn't really the only issue
dyslexia was starting to manifest itself
and for most families even today that's
where it starts
they can excel in other aspects of
school but in
in reading and math scores there is
definitely a big delta that starts
so you're about seven years old how did
you did you go to a doctor or
how did you know that you you had this
condition well obviously the angst
my parents felt was you know palpable
they were really concerned and and
you know they they were wondering what
was the learning disability and i went
through a
battery of tests i mean just everything
but that's what parents do
they try and solve and they go to
different specialists etc but what could
it be
i was extremely fortunate at that time
maybe serendipitous luck but i was
living in montreal canada
and there was an experimental program at
the university of mcgill
with marjorie golick and sam rabinowicz
who have become legends in the work
around dyslexia
their research is is everywhere but i
was in that
first cohort of of students it was it
was really tough because
what what they tried to teach is they
said look we know what this is this is
dyslexia
that's what it is and it manifests
itself in each of these students i think
at the time there was 12 of us
in the program and it's different for
all of them for example one of the
things that happened to me i'd be
walking down the street
and all of a sudden the universe would
shift 90 degrees
and i was lost i didn't know where i was
oh it you get i mean it was many years
ago kevin but you still
get real emotional about it you know
henry winkler the actor has talked about
how it caused a lot of friction in his
house there were lots of fights because
his parents thought he was being lazy
and they just didn't understand why
he couldn't focus yeah that is a problem
but the the solution to this
is to have you know dyslexia is not like
other learning disabilities it's
completely its own
issue and and the reason you know that
is there are very
very high functioning people that are
very dyslexic
you know the founder of jetblue is
dyslexic
many others have dealt with it and the
whole point is that at the end of the
day
it's the way it was taught to me the way
i got over it was
samuel binovitz used to say to me the
professor that he'd sit me down say look
you're the only person in your class
that can read a book
upside down in the mirror you have
superpowers
no one else can do that i can still do
that i can still do that today
you have to take this like a superpower
that's
unconstrained and focus it you have to
use it as a tool
and i thought wait a minute i have a
superpower that's incredible
how can i use it and that's really what
started working
all of a sudden i blew through in
reading and i started scoring in the top
quartile
because i felt that you know if i had to
read the book upside down in the mirror
i'd read the book upside down in the
mirror
you know because no one else could do it
and i said to sam listen
am i going to have to read in a mirror
for the rest of my life he said no no no
your brain is it's advancing it's
figuring things out
and of course he was right i'm a
ferocious reader now i mean i read
everything
but i can still do it upside down in a
mirror that's an added feat it's not a
bug
it's a feature that's the way i started
to think about dyslexia
and i also excelled in math i'm a
balance sheet guy i'm a financier you
know that's what i do now
because of sam and marjorie golic and my
message to parents that have dyslexic
children is
you've got to work with them to to at
that age to
make them understand they're gifted
that's what they have they have a power
and if they can understand that as a
gift
what is it about your personal
experience um
that still makes you emotional after all
this time
well it was very difficult for my mother
it really was
she was very worried about me i can
imagine being a mom myself you know
you'll go to the nth degree and the ends
of the earth for your kid
let me i got i got to get some kleenex i
just got to wipe my eyes give me one
second give me one sec
the the challenge is parents don't know
the outcome they don't know
if if if you know what the future holds
they
they're not sure what's going to happen
and that that puts a lot of pressure
on you know relationships and families
particularly if one sibling has it and
the other doesn't
because then you have a situation where
one's excelling right right away and the
other is falling behind it just puts a
horrible pressure on any family
but again i i say to people that this is
this is a unique learning disability
it's it's the it's one of the only
learning disabilities that can give
incredible functionality is the outcome
of of solving it
now i want to talk a little bit about
dyslexia in the workplace
um i think there are lots of
misconceptions that employers have about
dyslexic people and i'm just wondering
in your personal experience when you
were starting out did you let
potential employers know about your
dyslexia how did you deal with it
no that is not a requirement
and and i don't think you lead with that
because what they want are functional
employees and my attitude about
people that have dyslexia is they are
super functional
in many areas they they are very very
functional
and so they should be measured by that i
don't i don't like the idea that you
should put that on your resume or even
discuss it if you've dealt with it and
you can read and your math scores are
above average again or even average um
life is not just about
math and reading it's actually cognitive
skills that matter in the workplace
kevin um what if anything do you think
companies should be doing
maybe your own companies do to support
people with dyslexia
or other neurodiverse conditions like
adhd like
autism i think as a society we deserve
to support people
you know that are unfortunate with those
disabilities
and there's always in a large
corporation even a small in a place for
for for people that you know there's a
job that can be created that makes them
feel important and gives them
self-confidence
dyslexia however to me is a competitive
weapon
i would hire lots of dyslexics because i
know they can excel in certain things
in a remarkable way above the average
and so i would argue to employer that
you know this is this is not a concern
this is an opportunity
and i feel that way about many learning
disabilities people that have learning
disabilities are often very very
motivated to perform
for their own self-confidence reasons
and to prove their worth and that
not every employee does that there's
lots of lazy people out there
and and you will not find that in people
that have
learning disabilities they want to be
functioning
human beings and and provide um
productivity and and they've
they're myopically focused on it because
that's what gives them their own
identity and that's the thing that many
employers have figured out i mean we're
enlightened now
we weren't in the 60s and the 70s you
know we pushed those people out of the
workplace because we thought it would be
a competitive disadvantage
that's not the case today and where you
often see companies really support this
is in technology because it's the out of
the box
thinkers that make companies competitive
the crazy ones
the dyslexic ones you know kevin it is
it's clear that you've gained an awful
lot from what you call your superpower
but as you reflect back is there
anything you feel you lost
with your diagnosis i didn't get to go
to soccer games because i was constantly
in the clinic
as soon as school was over i would go
there for hours
because that the program was
experimental it was on the campus of
mcgill
i didn't have a normal upbringing from
that point of view and i missed out on
you know various
extracurricular activities um until i
was able to get to the place where i
could
you know maintain my scoring in mat in
math and reading you got to remember
something you know one of the reasons i
went into educational software
my first liquidity event was the sales
of a learning company
i was fascinated by what i went through
and and i
you know i kind of dedicated that career
to math and reading scores because
we became the largest company on earth
that tested math and reading scores
and we started these tests in software
when the price of the computer dropped
below a thousand dollars with
products like rita rabbit carmen san
diego
and you know math rabbit and all of
those titles
oregon trail you know that was me
working on
trying to solve this for parents so they
could do remedial work at home just like
i did in the clinic
those software titles really focused on
what matters in the school system that
we've developed
you have to advance through the grade
schools with
math and reading scores there is no
other way to do it you can't game the
system
when you think about the resources
people give to
other uh health issues conditions it
seems like
mental health and conditions like
dyslexia sort of go by the wayside
dyslexia is not one that gets financed a
lot by giving and
and for me um i'd like to see that
change because
it's one of those disabilities that if
well financed
and you know if we can provide therapy
for it the outcomes can be
remarkable it's one of those um
disabilities you can actually fix and
excel with and i think that's a very
very good investment
and i would add also that you know um
one of the reasons i'm an investor in in
a company like mind med
you know that is experimenting with
psychedelic drugs is
from my experience when i was young not
necessarily for dyslexia but for all of
the issues that plague people
40 percent of americans are affected in
one way or another by mental illness and
so
you know dyslexia is part of that
continuum but
we need to open our our vision to terms
of how we treat this and
obviously there's some really
interesting anecdotal data
about anxiety opioid addiction and other
afflictions in mental health that can be
resolved using things like micro dosing
lsd and psilocybins
that were viewed as scheduled narcotics
and bad things
and in the 60s we were looking at them
as medicine they're back in the fray
uh in clinical trials now with the fda
so i'm encouraged to see that we're
expanding the tool chest
of maybe ways to help people with mental
illness it's not specific to dyslexia
but that whole continuum is so important
to america and and i i'd say
when you start thinking lastly about
giving towards mental illness
think of dyslexia because a dollar
invested there
can have a remarkable return down the
road i think all of us with
this dyslexia have proven that if you
like that video
where did you see my next one don't
forget to click right over here
and subscribe